6
26 on your memorial day completely
preventable
tragedy you know even with the special
emphasis on driving
safely over a holiday weekend a wrong
way driver suspected of impairment was
involved in a double
fatality weekend crash near the
spaghetti bowl
and that was just hours after an nhp
cruiser investigating an
earlier crash in almost the exact same
spot was hit
by a different suspected dui driver
i want to give a shout out to the men
and women of the nevada highway patrol
and all law enforcement for their
relentless pursuit of safer roads
in the face of a sometimes seemingly
losing battle with real people who are
actively choosing to endanger
others and themselves on this day when
we honor the men and women who made the
ultimate sacrifice defending our country
we're left to ask
how many more of us are going to have to
mourn over needless
traffic deaths buckle up drive carefully
and
please please don't drink and drive
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com